alice hindi says her brother josh was
the life and soul of the party
at 21 he had so much ahead of him but in
november
he took his own life i've got really
happy memories of of my brother
i just wish he was he was still here
with me souvenirs from holidays together
are among the items alice uses to
trigger those fond memories
but after discovering how josh was able
to research suicide on the internet
before his death
she was determined to do more than just
remember him creating an online tool
to act as a safety net for others in
need of help
my main motivation for this is to
prevent other
families from going through the pain
and the complete devastation that this
causes
and if i can just save one more person
from from this
you know happening to them then as far
as i'm concerned i would have done my
job
the software alice created is called
ripple it's designed to intervene when
someone searches for harmful
content by redirecting users to a page
where they can seek help from charities
instead
the samaritan's helpline does already
appear at the top of such
searches but alice says it's not enough
what i'm trying to do is provide
much more of an interception before the
users get to those search results
and provide a range of different mental
health support options
so not just the samaritan's helpline
number that currently exists
but also a text service a web chat
facility
the downloading of resources or an app
given the impact of the pandemic on
mental health charities agree
urgent action is needed we need sites to
have robust content policies in place
that govern the type of content allowed
with effective mechanisms to remove
content that breaks their policies
or at the very least makes it much much
harder to find harmful content
online content encouraging suicide is
already illegal
and the government told sky news that
platforms must do more to stop it
appearing
it's hoped the new online harms bill
will help make the internet
a safer place by giving platforms a
legal duty of care to protect their
users but while such legislation is
welcomed
some believe more still needs to be done
iva bennett
sky news